so here we are now
we are in the era of
mandated vaccines in four different
cities uh notably new york new orleans
san francisco i'm not sure what the last
city was but uh it may be three i know
that there were three announced i know
san francisco and new york and they're
they're mandating this no medical
exemptions in new york as i've noted
several times
and now
we're at the point where they're saying
you need after eight months of booster
shot
which is i'm gonna get right on that
well here's here here's here's the first
thing i always say obviously like for
you when you got vaccinated you went to
a doctor and it was a doctor you trusted
and
would you call him a conservative doctor
uh yes
i think that's between you and him i got
nothing to do with it exactly i will say
people got these vaccine cards did did
any of you all ask why there were four
lines on it
and you only needed two and it says
other another yeah because they were
always expecting there to be boosters
and to be honest they even said this
they said we may require more in the
future it may become a seasonal thing
so so here's here's the point i want to
make real quick
we already had
one um
libertarian i suppose on twitter say if
i had a choice between a facility with a
mass mandate and a facility with a
vaccine passport i choose the vaccine
password because i'm already vaccinated
i like the choice i like how he creates
the choice where i can have this or i
can have this abuse of my liberty or
that abuse of my liberty i'd rather t
you know if i had to choose between
gonorrhea and syphilis i'd probably go
with gonorrhea and he says
that's the ultimate libert modern
libertarian uh conundrum reason.com but
he goes on to say i'm opposed to all of
the restrictions but i would just choose
that one and that's exactly the point
yes they say at first look just just get
it and my response is like if your
doctor wants it thinks you should you
keep your medical decisions between you
and a medical professional not internet
people or politicians yeah and then what
happens is because these people have all
just gotten it when the when when it
comes out that they're going to be
mandating for all these businesses they
say i don't care i already got the
vaccine right yeah now what happens now
you need a booster and they say well
i've already got the card and i've
already done this much i might as well
just go and get the booster what's the
problem is it's incrementalization into
authoritarianism i got no problem with
the vaccines i got no problem to even
extend with like going to countries
requiring i went to venezuela i had to
have a vaccine card i'd go to the doctor
get it filled out he signed it i went to
venezuela they said show us proof you've
got yellow fever and these other things
and i'm like here you go
the problem is that in these cities
they're barring people in violation of
their rights and i don't know
what scares me is i don't see it as
sustainable so i guess i should say this
when you mentioned before that you think
some people in oklahoma will not stand
for this kind of stuff i actually should
say
people everywhere won't even in new york
city i hope not but i just i i'm not
saying like
i actually i actually think a decent
amount of people everywhere will start
becoming fed up with this if you if you
look at new york you can see that less
than uh it's about 56 of the people are
vaccinated which means right now
about half of new york city cannot use
these services public accommodations how
long will that last until the system
breaks i i think it is unsustainable and
and
remember in it's not
just that it is a a conglomeration of
things it is your children being taught
that uh because of their race they are
you know either good or bad
or indifferent it is uh it is uh america
humiliated overseas in afghanistan it is
4.59 gas which i've been paying in l.a
wow it is uh
you know it is people say well you know
maybe you don't need cheeseburgers
because you know the weather in a
hundred years it is all these things
where they suddenly you know the the
elite suddenly got a chance to kind of
foist it's it's stuff on us and in seven
months it's been a freaking disaster as
we predicted
and i i think people are just getting
fed up now the thing that makes me
one of the things that gives me hope i
was alive when saigon fell i was 10
years old i remember it i was very
engaged as a kid
uh in in news and current events and i
remember distinctly and i remember
feeling much like i'm feeling now except
now i didn't have friends who you know
got shot in afghanistan and are now
wondering why they went and got shot
but uh
five years after afghanistan or after
saigon fell
america elected ronald reagan and it
started
you know it it gave us you know 11 years
later america was its height of its
power and i was physically there at the
place america was its greatest power i
was at seventh core main command post
during desert storm during the land war
the greatest military force ever
assembled
uh the most decisive defeat of an enemy
in all of military history arguably was
the allied attack in a
ground attack and desert storm and i was
a seven core main command post i heard
radio calls i later read about in books
so i was physically standing there at
america's greatest pinnacle of power the
undisputed power in the world and it's
been all downhill for 30 years from
there
but it doesn't mean
we can't go back you know a society can
hit low points we can hit the hit the
depths of our biorhythm and still go
back up i'm optimistic tim i'm always
optimistic because i
you know there's something about
americans
there's something about our constitution
and these are unique and they are
special and i i just i just feel in my
heart and maybe i'm crazy and stupid and
maybe i'm idealistic god help me i
thought that was
surgically removed from me in law school
but i think we come back from this but
it's important that we understand how
far down we are it's like the alcoholic
has to take
you know inventory when he hits bottom
but during uh would you say that during
the vietnam era the country was at this
level of
authoritarianism no fracturing political
tribalism uh somewhat remember there was
a full-scale terrorist
low-intensity yeah low-intensity uh uh
conflict thousands of bombings in the
early 70s thousands in the early 70s i
mean they weren't killing people left
and right but they were kind of killing
people it was mostly shocking wasn't it
a lot of it was uh a lot of it were
message bombings but there were you know
cops being shot down the street
uh the capital was blown up
they tried to blow up a number of
targets managed to blow up themselves
which you know that's a win-win
um
unfortunately after after that a lot of
them were absorbed into academia
and uh look we and then raise some kids
who wanted to become da's in san
francisco yes chesa bodine yeah we um
what we need
what look
here's what i'm afraid of and here's
what we need we need
not ronald reagan but a reagan-like
figure who is willing to come in and
push his agenda towards
the kind of uh civil rights civil
liberties that we're talking about not
exactly like ronald reagan not the same
policies but a a communicator who is
forthright and focused
i am worried that what we're going to
get is a real authoritarian because
people are going to say i can't take
this chaos that's right
i can't take this chaos
there are three options a free society
where everyone has rights a society
where our authoritarian rules a society
where they're authoritarian rules i want
number one i can live with number two
number three it's war was abraham
lincoln authoritarian yes that's right
he was yes he was and he was one of my
heroes he he
his pick portrait was on my family's
wall at my grandmother's house uh in
chambersburg pennsylvania burned twice
by the confederacy right down the road
from gettysburg which is one of the
first places i was taking as a kid
so yes a guy can be authoritarian and
not necessarily
authoritarian in context and in a
limited way
with the idea of coming back from it
james buchanan right he was the one who
led us into uh the civil war basically
yeah he was uh the uh biden of his era
exactly well that's what i was gonna say
is biden buchanan jbjb jb
oh no except i'm not sure biden
i'm not sure buchanan was uh you know
grandpa bad finger but let's leave this
person but can we can we get like a
numerologist now to like do the numbers
and be like the correlation between the
two well let me let me let me text my
phrenologist there you go see what he's
so it so a lot of people were wondering
if this period of biden would be so bad
that you will get a major
you know
blowout election in 2022 and 2024 with
your will
i mean i'd like to say that but i think
i've thought that in the past
you know in 2018 i was like wow i was
like with with how crazy the democrats
have gotten and how inconsistent and
broken and then we get the squad
you actually get more uh absurd
look the the democrat party has been
pulled to the left the uh republican
party has been pulled uh
to the patriotic uh because for a long
time the republican party was
you know an establishment party it was
the party of the guy who pulled up and
uh uh
you know stepped out of his limousine
and fired all you guys uh who worked at
the uh carrier air conditioning plant
and said hey your job's going to oaxaca
don't worry we'll uh teach you to code
or something and he looks exactly like
mitt romney by the way
and look the republican party ignored
normal people the guys who built this
country fed it fueled it fought for it
they ignored them
in in in favor of this giant corporate
nightmare i look you you got to
understand i was a normal republican i i
subscribed to the weekly standard before
it became you know uh legally anti-trump
before it became a jeffrey tube and uh
zoom inspiration material
um
and i
i i only changed because of what i see i
was not a supporter of trump when he was
running
uh before he ran before he won the
primary after he won the primary i was a
reluctant supporter i became an active
supporter when he proved himself
i i supported going into iraq i support
going into afghanistan i thought these
were good ideas i actually participated
in a successful nation-building
operation in kosovo
very different situation though
i changed my minds because my mind
because the facts changed and i love
what these guys on twitter like you know
in a 10 years ago you had different
ideas yes
yes
when things changed and i i reevaluated
under new facts yes i changed my mind
you you have correctly assessed what i
have done good point
aces you are correct and i don't delete
the old stuff oh yeah several years ago
i didn't own any guns
now i own many oh now i got a bear at
m82 nice i think that's right holy crap
what do you got bears around here bear
we do yeah
actually
that's not for bears i mean it could
have well bears daddies you know otters
yeah so but uh uh
no it's it's you you have a i went i
remember i was talking to someone who
posted on facebook some meme like
there's no reason to own any weapon they
said no no self-respecting hunter
whatever use an assault weapon and so
then
uh i was not a hunter i responded with
like showing like you know a polymer tip
450 bushmaster versus like a nine
millimeter which is used in combat or
like a 556 and then i'm like
which one do you think the hunter uses
they use the stopping power for large
animals and i was like your argument
makes no sense but the interesting thing
was they came back with like oh they're
right wing gun nuts no one's taking your
guns here's a list of my guns that have
been banned already
and like and and then he responded with
what do you need any of those for
and so i actually said i'm going to
engage this guy in good faith and i had
a list i said okay and then i explained
the purpose of every gun like barrel
length caliber like hunting a small game
like i got a break action 410 it's like
a turkey shot you know what i mean
because we have wild turkeys sometimes
we don't really we don't use it here but
when you go to west virginia you gotta
get rid of some of the turkeys because
there are pests if there's too many then
you gotta then you get something more
powerful if there's wild boars infesting
an area deer can become a very big
problem and then you have home defense
you've got different uh you know options
there and then i was like we'll put the
m82 at the bottom we'll come back to
that one later and then i said
and then and then my response to that
one was because i have a right to own it
and it's none of your business yeah
because outside of anything else i can
easily explain the function of these
things this one it's just it's mine yeah
i i want it which is another grounds for
not taking the vaccine why don't you
want the vaccine because i don't
done da argument over that
see people don't understand about rights
tim they think that rights are just uh
like a brand of like special privilege
but if you you know you know if you have
a really good reason though the right
has to give way and as i i said before a
lot of these people have the whole
rights responsibility thing like uh was
his name uncle ben and spider-man with
great power comes great responsibility
no
no the idea of rights is no
responsibility rights are a given
otherwise they're not rights they're
just privileges and we've seen what you
would do with privileges the founding
fathers
said that we have uh you know it's
self-evident we have we have inalienable
rights that were granted to us by our
creator yes we can do them even if you
think it's a bad idea and they'll try
and stop you yes and even with the
constitution and the bill of rights they
still infringe upon all of them even
though the founding fathers outlined
that these shall not be infringed but
here we are and one of the biggest
disasters of our uh institutions is the
supreme court failing to aggressively
police attacks on our rights every time
they pass on a
you know you can't sing in church
the supreme court is meaningless the
supreme court
would have had some moral authority if
it stood up for the things it should
then people would listen now people are
like well you know kavanaugh is just
going to roll over because he's got to
go to the country club
a guy i don't understand because if they
did that to me
holy crap it would be a jihad
so
they would be my project i think it was
will chamberlain who told us that the
reason the supreme court doesn't get
aggressive on some of these cases
because they have no enforcement ability
and if they push hard on something it
will reveal the emperor has no clothes
which it has when the supreme court
ruled that the eviction moratoriums were
illegal completely in every sense yep
and the cdc has no authority to do it
then biden said
there's anything
yeah whatever screw the supreme court
right my my issue with rights being
inalienable i mean the way it's written
is they can't an alien bully can't can't
be taken away they're there but
like the reality like that's kind of the
myth we tell ourselves the reality is if
someone with a lot of weapons wants to
just say this is a new world with new
sets of
rights and laws and ideas then that is
what it is well simply because rights
can be violated doesn't make them not
rights it makes somebody a violator of
rights and you
have a moral obligation to resist
no no no right or look people are going
to want to take what's yours you may
do you think people have a right to
express themselves freely it depends on
the situation so that's is that a no
yeah if you're if you're out in the
woods and if you make a sound the the
panther knows where you are and we'll
rip your throat out then no you don't
you don't have that right
you have the ability you have the right
you just got to defend it right which is
why you need that bushmaster but i mean
the reality is we're squishy bodies but
i don't i don't think you understand
what a right means right so yeah exactly
we got to define what that shouldn't
mean if if somebody wanted to speak
freely should they be stopped
well depends on the situation if you're
going to alert your presence then yeah
they should be stopped
i'm just saying like okay so there are
circumstances which you think people
shouldn't be allowed to express
themselves yes right i don't i don't
agree with that i think people have a
right to express themselves no matter
what the concept of the military the
consequences are their choice
there's a difference between saying well
you might give away your position it's
like okay well you're allowed to do it
that's your decision not mine and i'll
tell you this and if i'm standing next
to you and we're in the woods and you
want to start screaming without your
lungs i have a right to walk away and
i'll say ian you go ahead yeah but if my
sword is going to get us killed then
i will leave
no
my your my rights are more important
than your life
and it's not even close and no offense
but my rights are more important than
your they're also more important than my
life i will not live where i cannot
speak freely where i cannot worship as i
see fit i will not live that way what
about the right i will die before i do
what about the right to pursue happiness
that's not a right that's that is this
that is a
that is that is a a a preamble
rights are specific i see you have life
and liberty in the pursuit of happiness
and that was a that was like a
conveyance of feeling about what their
goal was not they didn't they didn't
make the first amendment the right to
pursue happiness yeah it's nebulous and
vague and can't be enforced
yes and and and the bill of rights is
not
the only rights it simply expects some
uh in fact they thought many many people
thought we don't need a bill of rights
this stuff's obvious
well
thank you was the anti-federalists i
don't remember as well i think was the
anti-federal store like ah we're not
giving you that power it's got to be
outlined in fact i think there was
originally 17 in the bill of rights and
they decided to combine some remove some
and boy did they screw up the second you
know why
because the original article that they
wrote up actually said even if you are
not a part of a militia your right to
keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed but they were worried that if
they included that people would use it
as an argument to avoid conscription
so they said let's just say you have the
right to let's just let's just give the
uh damn brady group
some to try and hang it stupid it
doesn't matter it doesn't it doesn't
matter though you know why because
without still clear without culture it's
meaningless oh of course that's my point
rights have to be look rights have to be
defended and forced but no no ian i'm
not saying that your rights don't exist
i'm saying that if you don't have a
culture that's willing that's going to
agree with you or recognize your rights
then the constitution
the constitution doesn't grant you your
rights it tells the government not to
infringe upon these specific rights
right but it was if you have a culture
that says will infringe anyway be
prepared to defend right but it was the
the fathers the founding fathers that
decided which rights are inalienable no
it wasn't like those are not no no no it
wasn't like god no
no they didn't ian they said let's
create a list of rights to stop the
government from infringing they even say
that rights that aren't included are not
are just because they didn't include in
the bill of rights it doesn't mean you
don't have those rights they were like
let's pick the best like outline for
what it is to live in like a human yeah
society and they agreed on it these are
puritan puritan christian white men that
agreed on a set of rights well does it
mean that they're the only rights or
that they're the best rights no ian you
are wrong they didn't all agree on what
rights were in fact there was an
argument over whether they'd have a bill
of rights what they said was we have
rights then which ones do we put in out
of 17 they get down to 10 and they said
these are the ones that protect the
country and they negotiated and
compromised there were many people who
felt there were some rights you should
have and somewhat you shouldn't have
some people were were slave owners and
some people were abolitionists they
clearly did not agree
so what i guess some cultures might have
a bill of rights that say you have the
right to three wives
yeah but they're wrong well who says
though
our military our constitution does not
say you have a right to anything
yes that's correct no positive right it
does it says no these these rights are
yours no it's our government can't wait
they're right the
government not infringement our rights
are negative rights when the the rights
that the enumerated rights that is the
ones are specifically set out because
those are not the only ones they're
specifically reserve other rights the
enumerated rights are all negative the
bill of rights the bill of rights they
are all negative in the sense that they
uh the government cannot infringe on
these there are no rights that you have
to something you have no right to a
house or a job or to my labor but in
certain pronouns and saying they have
the obligation to not infringe on that
right they're essentially saying you
have that right
yeah so they're they're acknowledging it
no that well the brights come from god
that's what it says it's written in that
it's like god
come on guys i don't think you
understand the philosophy
god gave it yeah i think it'd be really
important that if you're where else
would rights come from
you're gone ian you need to actually
like
read some theology and some religion to
understand what they're saying because i
think the the problem here is that you
fundamentally don't understand the
philosophy behind inalienable rights you
seem to think that some guys read a
bible and just arbitrarily decided
something because you don't understand
what it means to have intrinsic inherent
value well i see that there is value to
it i acknowledge like the free speech is
legit but it's also subjective to our
society and our culture right now no i
can't a right can't be subjective or
right is inherent to every human being
and you know even even the victim of the
taliban who's got an ak-47 to his head
has a right to speak freely even if
someone's going to blow his head off
because he does it
uh and when i say the rights come from
god i look like i'm a religious guy
there are people who aren't religious
who just unders who are humanists
they'll call themselves humanist and say
that as a human being i have these
rights and you know at the end the the
effect is
uh similar in that they are a given they
are outside debate you cannot debate the
right to do it because the right exists
that's why i reject all these balancing
tests well you know tim it's important
that you uh have free speech but you
know if your speech is harmful
well look speech is the only speech that
matters the only time rights matter is
when it's harmful or forbidden or
unwanted or unreasonable
otherwise it doesn't you don't need a
right
no one will care there's
there are certain rights that are
actually universal in fact um you know
uh
in all in all cultures
you know
there are basic like tenets that allow
us to survive as a species better and i
think a lot of those are codified in the
u.s constitution but for people to rely
the reason i'm bringing this up is
because i'm afraid that people are going
to rely and be like these are my rights
this paper says so so no one can touch
me and like dude you have to fight what
yeah if you want those to be real you
we're on the same sheet of music there
and that's you know that's that's why i
believe every american should own guns
that's why i believe every american
should be uh trained to participate in
the defense of our community and
constitution and
i mean there's the serious challenge
though of what happens when the bus
pulls up for the australians and says
you know we're going to be taking you
and relocating you to the alternative
quarantine hub to the relocatable
campsite we're going to be color
coordinating you know your outfits and
your and your and your uh cabins yeah
unfortunately they're going to finish
their fosters and get on board they
actually i don't think they have fosters
in australia i think they have fosters
in australia i don't think so no i think
it's like i think it's like
the old milwaukee no i'm pretty sure
it's not there i have friends from
australia and they're like we don't have
that you don't have fosters i don't know
what's happening
yeah i'm appreciative that's not sydney
watson can you continue yeah yeah she
said i'm from australia i always make
that joke uh or like a half joke to my
australian friends i'd be like oh so you
guys like drink fox foster's like
budweiser like we don't have that's
american
and i'd be like really really okay but
maybe thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you